mais vous êtes vous êtes pâte avec jean
marie et jean marie c'est mon frère
c'est votre frère était plus que mon
meilleur ami c'est mon frère c'est
vraiment votre frère vous avez c'est
travailler plus pendant des années puis
ciel mais sait il est parrain de ma
fille je suis parrain de son fils a pas
je veux dire c'est là c'est la famille
royale et nous dire ce que vous pensez
et vous aussi
jean-marie de ce qui se passe dans leur
garde et ilir il était chez nous pour
son conflit avec muriel robin regarde
site un truc à lui dire je lui dirai
quoi soit aaa
je lui dirai noël je t'adore tué
énormément de talent et ça me fait de la
peine de savoir que nous n'avons jamais
été amis alors que moi je les ai
toujours pensé
en tout cas moi je suis toujours ton ami
donc c'est quand tu veux on espère que
muriel robin et jean marie bigard vont
se rabibocher questions seront
franchement tu connais bien alors parce
que moi ce que j'en pensais que on voit
toute la douceur et la tendresse de jean
marais et jean-marie quelqu'un d'hyper
sensible jean marie sy je veux pas
dressant un portrait de lui en faire un
homme fatigué parce que c'est un comique
à la pêche et qui fait beaucoup beaucoup
de dates mais l'a 65 balais les
diabétiques et il a des combats aussi
personnelle et il est hyper sensible
donc là il tombe de l'armoire sans
muriel unique qui sont pas un mythe
tombe de l'armoire à scellés fait
beaucoup de peine et et muriel je la
comprends quand elle s'investit dans une
cause bien sûr très noble equipo il faut
défendre à tout cramé mais je crois
qu'elle s'est un peu pris les pieds dans
le tapis quelques clips qui mélange tout
et c'est pas gentil que de dire à
quelqu'un que c'est pas son ami parce
qu'ils sont partagé beaucoup de choses
et dont j'ai été témoin parce que je
connais j'ai donné muriel en même temps
que jean marie donc moi j'étais dans
dans la coulisse à écrire donc je sais
je connais tous les dossiers et je
comprends que ça fait de la peine à jean
mario je peux dire un mot juste longue
que je veux qu'ils connaissaient de
pourquoi muriel robin dit ça elle a une
raison il ya quelque chose derrière tout
ça au lot de la jeune fille parle moi je
la croyais je la connais et je ne vais
pas dire que muriel et mon ami c'est
quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
un talent immense mais je risquerais
jamais à dire que c'est mon ami est la
raison mériel un ami c'est quelqu'un
qu'on peut appeler le chômage est déjà
appelée muriel la dernière fois je vais
proposer une pièce est là lui en 24
heures elle a été très très amical à
madonna un retour voilà mais je ne
connais pas muriel robin dans tous ses
recoins ses méandres
comme je connais jean marie frère au
coeur c'est mon frère
voilà c'est un teyssen a mis mon métier
j'ai beaucoup d'amis je dois aussi dire
que je te considères comme on dit c'est
très gentil je le partage franck on ne
connaît pas depuis longtemps moi j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup d'amis oui voilà c'est
très important ça fait de la peine ça de
voir jean-marie qu'il ya ka de la peine
ça me fait de la peine
et c'est vrai que c'est un nounours ah
là on peut dire qu'il est grossier qui
est vulgaire
si l'un c'est gros comme ça et j'ai il a
eu vraiment ils étaient affectés sur
cette séquence hier eric naulleau ça
vous a touché mi temps mais ce côté pas
vous aviez un peu attaqué jean marie
voilà mais légitime qu'il est méchant
non non non pas ce qu'il dit les choses
il est méchant et seulement qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé
non j'ai bien aimé la fin enfin et c'est
dommage qu'il n'ait pas réagi comme ça
tout de suite moi je pense que quand
elle a dit qu'ils devaient être punis
ils n'auraient pas d'une insulte et il
aurait dû lui dire à une comique peut
pas dire ça d'un autre comique et tu
peux pas appeler à la censure vous le
savez dit bon grosse connaissent à
partir de là c'était assez partagés se
retient oui tu sais pas après il m'a un
peu dérouté parce que là il est vraiment
touchant dans las dans la dernière heure
et moi je n'ai course que ma fille
connais bien parce que c'est son ami moi
je connais mieux comme ça c'est en effet
quelqu'un qui a l'air d'être à vif
donc je comprends mieux pourquoi ça a
dégénéré dernier détail ce que jean
marais a tendance à parler trop fort
quand il s'énerve voire même à créer ce
qui énerve un peu les gens alors je sais
pas si je trahis un secret je crois
qu'il a déjà dit jean marc il est sourd
d'une oreille à l'esv un truc étant
gamin donc c'est vrai qu'il se rend pas
compte qu'ils parlent trop fort et ça ça
le ça le dessert parfois aussi lors d'un
christophe aussi d'ailleurs
il est sympathique mais en tout cas ça
va tourner et on attend c'est
généralement les gens qui parlent le
plus fort et qui sont le plus grossier
on va dire généralement derrière c'est
des vrais nounours et qui sont
extrêmement minces comme jamais on a un
projet
laurent baffie quand même en personne à
qui on a taxé à en donner avec cette
bête histoire par rapport à ma rien moi
oui on a été de lâcher de [ __ ]
ensemble on est obligé de se justifier
ça serait possible aujourd'hui décrire
tout ce qui est humain franchement non
aujourd'hui plus rien n'est possible on
fait un pilote drôle il n'est pas
diffusée oui parce que l'émission est
encore plus drôle dans tout il faut que
je veux dire non mais non pourriez faire
le lâcher de [ __ ] aujourd'hui non non
non non moi je suis je pourrais tout
faire mais ce serait pas diffusée moi je
reste le même mais après on avoue derosa
hélas d'être en direct pour moi c'est
vous met une pression supplémentaire
même région mais élaboré pour la
question ma femme est terrorisée
kankankan les batteries chan d'y entrer
pour l'action bien sûr tu pourrais
écrire mais ça ne passerait chaud non
salue chaque soldat et j'ai toujours une
pensée pour mes idoles qui sont coluche
et pierre desproges
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui jaurès ou
leur carrière oui parce que c'était de
génie ouais mais mais mais comment il
aurait pu évoluer dans ce monde qui est
qui est hyper censuré est apparu après
se pose la question
géraldine moi je les trouvais hier
absolument bouleversant à fleur de peau
extrêmement sincère et moi je pense que
l'humour était robot fait en fait
aujourd'hui traverse une zone de
turbulences et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a plus droit de dire à une femme
[ __ ] t [ __ ] alors que blanche
gardin par exemple à la carte ont
visiblement on digard n'a plus la tarte
et blanche n'a pas que la carte elle a
le talent mais là non je l'habille gare
n'auraient pas droit de dire parce que
même une sorte de bréviaire autorisé
pour certains comme les surfaces plus de
la part d'une femme aujourd'hui comme le
plus choquant dans l'histoire s'arrêtait
que muriel tête une comique avec la même
sanction pour un pour un autre comique
et ça n'a pas été très
déjà pour duboscq oui c'était un débat
c'est normal ce tribunal aux pauvres et
distribue les bons points et les mauvais
points c'est très gênant alors
effectivement lui l'a dit kaunas je
pense qu'il a parlé avec sentries
abandonné mathieu juste un mois je pas
si vous la passe et hier il ya ilahi là
sur son facebook sur instagram il a
répondu longuement à muriel robin est
sûre on a tendance à mourir de rire
moi ce qui me gêne dans cette histoire
c'est pas c'est pas jean marie bigard
c'est muriel robin j'aimerais tellement
chez nous écoute elle m'a tellement fait
rire qu'elle redevienne rôle qu'elle
arrête de devenir la ministre des femmes
même côté l'état
on n'est pas couché ou dans des
émissions il est toujours grave elle est
toujours dure elle quitte les plateaux
elle est quotidienne drôle et très émue
elle a tellement de talent et voilà
quelques conduites s'amuse avec elle
parce que je veux dire la vérité je
t'adore muriel mais là tu es devenu
chiante et c'est pénible
oui non simplement elle s'investit
totalement dans les causes et les les
familles là tu sais c'est une cause qui
est pas mise seulement sous les
projecteurs une femme meurt tous les
trois jours et les choses n'ont pas
changé pardon de de connaître un peu le
sujet les choses n'ont pas changé en
cinquante ans font donc on peut
féliciter muriel pour son combat bien
sûr mais après il faut qu'elles sachent
raison garder
mais il peut prendre un peu d avoir des
attentions délicates pour des gens qui
pensent être son ami voilà franck est ce
que je tombe enceinte et de la brenne
compose pas on sait qu'on comme une
pinède
je suis sûr que tu étais fan de jean
marie tome est évidemment non mais c'est
surtout que c'est tellement difficile
d'être comique c'est tellement difficile
d'être drôle j'en ai beaucoup autour de
moi
c'est un métier très difficile pour moi
alors à partir du moment où il y en a un
qui fait pas la bonne vanne fait des
mauvaises vannes que tahri vérité on a
faim
non mais tu vois ce jeu c'est sûr mais
le problème c'est que si on se fait
tomber dessus tout de suite et se faire
taxer de de toutes les insultes qui vont
avec parce que t'as pas fait la bonne
vanne c'est compliqué je pense aussi que
les comics doivent être conscients du
monde dans lequel ils vivent
et à chaque fois se tenir au courant des
causes là effectivement c'était ce
n'était pas le bon moment de faire cette
valve c'est peut-être ça n'a jamais été
le bon moment vos façades vannes mais je
sais que les comiques font de leur mieux
quoi pour essayer de nous faire rire
alors bas parfois il y en a une qui est
moins drôle que l'un des deux en or ni
son va pas changer à nos âges jean marc
est un comique vulgaire moi je suis un
comique graveleux nous dans notre
famille on à désensibiliser les mots et
ils n'ont pas la même valeur et donc on
se rend plus compte parce qu'on est
entre nous on passe notre temps à
rigoler avec des potes à déconner en
famille et on ne se rend plus compte que
ce que nous ce qui nous paraît normal
n'est plus la normale pour les autres
dom